I've become immune nothing weirds me out
anymore I've seen too much [ __ ] I just
want to know what it's like to feel
again what is this try not to get
weirded out challenge curated by Jessica
could it be could my prayers finally
have been answered let's check it out
okay Jessica I'll accept your challenge
let's see if you can weird me out number
one dancing man wearing a horse mask
cooks with the wild mushroom ain't
nothing weird about that it's making me
feel very hungry so far is that an anime
pillow
[ __ ] yeah what did you buy that one that
was [ __ ] sweet is he naked oh that's
not even weird it's not even naked I
mean I'm not wearing it up or anything
if anything I'm turned on
don't tell Marcia of course it's
Japanese a [ __ ] course what is he
doing if he found mushrooms okay it's
cooking the mushrooms how long this is
garbage I don't know how you found this
video Jessica but it didn't weird me out
good Zilla dance there's a Donkey Kong
soundtrack [ __ ] ya the Godzilla dance I
love this [ __ ] [ __ ] lip for the
gorilla desk
it's my favorite damn okay next
challenge a for asthma it's getting
trickier oh my god that's a great what
is that
I am weirded out that's this hilarious I
feel fantastic alright what is this
I'm scared what the [ __ ] is that
please be over it's not weird I need a
challenge
Jessica you [ __ ] give me another one
this one just has a Russian Title I know
your Russians are watching and I know
you were [ __ ] weird so let's next
video there's good reason for my
glistening skin and how I shine and how
my pores are so clean and clear he's
gonna eat from yourself
I eat little babies what you can't just
say I eat little babies babies I
screaming you'll wink I don't think this
guy should be allowed to say the word
babies I is just my personal opinion and
I'd appreciate it if you'd blink maybe
once or twice and nod and hug and a high
five each other I would make me feel
great enthusiasm this is a special time
this should be illegal and whoever made
this should be put to prison that's all
I got to say about that Jessica you
[ __ ] this is some Eastern European [ __ ]
man
saspa saspa the harbour gonna give me
it's the same piss-ass
I don't know what ip's is but I don't
think it matters
this is [ __ ] my jam it
they're gonna give me piss-ass oh my god
I am NOT the sweat on this head before
you I am NOT the headband or the glasses
that you see how he [ __ ] his insane I am
NOT Facebook [ __ ] I'd really thought he
was Facebook for a second there I am not
the friends I keep I am not even my
family he looks like a penis all right
what do we got unicorn unicorn ooh this
looks like an awesome video nope nope
nevermind baby Oh God
oh this is awkward show me the pizza Oh
can the people in the background please
shut the [ __ ] up I'm trying to listen to
the unicorn now weird about it
this is what friends do they do this
what death nope I feel violated
I feel sexually assaulted but I'm not
weirded out [ __ ] last video the laughs
aw
holiday lyrics I leave the lyrics that
are better than what they're playing on
the radio
I can't do this anymore
burn it burn it
Oh God fine you win all right I'm not
doing this [ __ ] anymore
[ __ ] you made by Jessica and just so you
know when I dated PewDiePie what don't
let no don't listen to her he was a
nasty person I tagged him on tumblr as
hashtag problematic Malcolm says he only
in it for the money and I agree that and
his dick is small Felix
not Malcolm Malcolm is 19 inches this
was not made by Malcolm but by Jessica
who is dating Malcolm forever and his
hime it seems like that's the truth
leave it like we enjoyed subscribe to
come bro today and as always stay
awesome max he's clearly a pet oh my god